oh somebody else who is at 2-0 is now
with us in the studio katarina nemtsova
who won her game
as well katarina congratulations good to
join us were your thoughts about this
game
did you feel like you were commanding
throughout or was there a big event that
occurred that changed the evaluation in
your favor
thank you uh i think it was a very
complicated game at the beginning my
time management was not very good so i
was in time trouble a little bit uh but
it was always like you know we were
staring at each other and i was thinking
about pushing like at some moment maybe
c5 or e5 but i wasn't doing anything and
she was also shuffling pieces around so
it looked like we are just waiting who's
gonna strike first
so what happened that caused you to
suddenly be up material
i managed to find i think a nice kind of
reshuffling of pieces where i'm really
threatening to activate both of my
bishops
and i have this amazing bishop on b4
that's like you know blocking e1 square
so anytime i have f5 like the e6 phone
is really weak but no one can attack it
so i'm very happy with that and i'm just
waiting for my bishop from b7 to be
active as well
the only thing is like i think about
playing c5 but i don't want to lock my
bishop on b4 as well because then it's
like just a pawn it cannot go back it
cannot do anything
uh
so yeah i wasn't really sure what to do
so i wanted to move the bishop back
maybe a reshuffle and now to play c5 she
played f4 and joined you with this
weakened square
looks like you were the one who will
take advantage of this weakness on e4
more than she could take e5 yeah i was
not expecting f4 i i don't think it was
very necessary but it's very
uncomfortable to like think what you
want to do because like you want to play
g3 or h3 like the bishop is really
strong there i may play f4 if i want to
i am still threatening c5
so it's it's not a comfortable position
for white indeed very complex we jump
ahead and suddenly when you had your
queen on e4 that seemed to be just a
fantastic position for you you took the
pawn and here you took on e4 and
that configuration of queen on e4 work
on b2 you were active even though it
looked like she had passed pawns but
they weren't going anywhere yeah the
white's position is locked because i'm
attacking g2 sodium has to go to g1 or
queen g1 or something oh it's a mistake
i wasn't sure what else you want to do
queen g1 don't listen to the computer
just keep going so it's so it's just
like uh
white is really just defending against
checkmate and then i have to just grab
the pawns around and figure out how to
how to win there was one moment if we
just can come back
to
uh it's like five moves back because i
wanted to do a sacrifice there
more more more back after i play bishop
e4 for the first time so
i just want to show you know back
one thing that i was really calculating
a lot more
almost there no back still back
okay here so i planned bishop e4 bishop
d3 and i was calculating a lot instead
of returning to take on d4
and there is like cool lines like bishop
takes d4 i mean pontex b4 bishop takes
d4 and now i thought about having bishop
takes f4
and after rook takes f4 rotates d4 i
thought e5 e5 i mean i can do rook takes
d4 but
probably she can just play bishop takes
e4 and like there is check it was just
so complicated i was thinking for five
minutes because if it works i think i'm
winning
the problem is it doesn't work
that's usually a problem they don't work
because now the pawn takes the rock on
f4 i just hate that when
it doesn't exactly yeah
and bishop d5 right and suddenly it's
two bishops versus a rook at no contact
so i spent like five minutes there and i
was like six minutes on the clock but i
was like it should it should work
because because it just looks perfect
like all my pieces are active so that's
like when strategically are good like
the tactic needs to strike in but it
just wasn't working so i was like no it
has to work and then i would just like
okay i have to return you left alone
well you did get a winning dominant
position at the end you're now a
2-0 in the tournament have you ever been
a 2-0 in the u.s championship um i think
i was in like 2017 16 i think when i was
leading for some time the tournament yes
i remember i remember what do you guys
do different this time i i have much
less pressure on myself
and i just i mean
i wasn't sure i'm going to win this game
i wasn't better it was it was equal so
i'm just going to continue playing my
best sounds good all right well thank
you so much good luck tomorrow thank you
thank you for having me hey
congratulations scotch